- The only way to actually
drink this garbage
is to add all of these
packets and this vanilla thing
and this vanilla thing
and this vanilla thing.
(bass thumping beat)
- So, we've been dating almost four years.
- We've been dating for a year and a half.
I'm up and about at 8:30 and 8:45.
And then if I can sleep
in, I'm going till 2:00.
- I will wake up around 7:30 A.M.
Go downstairs, have a hearty breakfast,
steel-cut oatmeal, and
I'd put in a banana.
And I'll just have a couple of Pop-tarts.
- I brush my teeth before
I get in the shower.
That is bee line efficient, right?
Cause I'm using the time
the shower's warming up.
I brush my teeth.
- Try to meditate for 15 or 20 minutes.
- Everyone talks about
how I need to meditate.
It's such a great thing.
- I think we've gone long
enough, I can admit this
that I do blow dry my hair.
- I'll give it a try. We'll see.
Maybe I'll just be a new person tomorrow
because I meditated.
- No, you can't place those
crazy expectations on it.
(laughing)
- I feel awkward doing
my hair with a shirt on.
I always widen the neck and
then fit it over my head
so I don't mess my hair up.
I'll be very specific here, so
you know your routine. Okay?
(gentle chiming bells)
- Steve also loves coffee
and I absolutely hate coffee.
- I also hate oatmeal and I hate Pop-tart.
So I feel like I'm just
gonna start off the day
in a really crappy mood.
- You're gonna feel great.
(gentle chiming bells)
(bass thumping beat)
- I'm so used to being up at this hour
that I've just been lying
here in this empty bed.
- Okay, I'm up.
- This looks like a
whole lot of yuck. Mm-mm.
- I'm gonna brush my teeth
first cause that's what he does.
- I'm attempting to meditate.
It's been two minutes
and I'm already so bored of my self.
- Okay, I'm gonna turn on the shower
and I'm gonna brush my teeth.
- I'm almost hoping that
I have some left-over
make-up residue somewhere on my face
or else I'll just look like a white ghost.
( water dripping)
- I'm at 7/11 right
now, passing by the soda
which is what I want.
This coffee is definitely
making me sweat. I don't
even feel energized.
I just feel like I am sweating so much
and my stomach hurts.
So, thank you coffee.
(lighthearted guitar music)
- Breaking your routine
makes you really upset.
- The reason I'm struggling this morning
is cause I haven't had enough caffeine
and I'm used to drinking three
Coke Zeros by this point.
- I don't know if you don't
brush your teeth for very long
but like the shower was
warm and I was only halfway
through brushing my teeth. Whatever.
- You brush your teeth
for too long, I think.
- If I had to blow dry
my hair every single day,
it would add an extra 10
to 15 minutes to my routine
cause it just takes so long.
- Takes me 30 seconds.
- I love how my routine
includes oatmeal and meditation.
I sound like I'm in my 70s.
- The reason we're really doing this video
is cause Steve wanted to come
out as a 70-year-old man.